después de mucho tiempo de no trabajar
sobre el tema en esta ocasión les voy a
presentar un problema sobre cómo usar la
transformada de la plaza para resolver
ecuaciones lineales no homogéneas
y vamos a comenzar con una para
calentarnos un poco
hace tiempo que no trabajaba yo con ese
tipo de problemas
así que si tenemos la ecuación
la segunda derivada
dejé más que y eso es igual a seno de 2t
y nos dan algunas condiciones iniciales
de 0 es igual
a 2 y ya prima de 0 es igual a 1 y se
han visto los vídeos anteriores
recordarán que lo que tenemos que hacer
es tomar la transformada de laplace de
todos los términos de esta expresión y
luego hacer la transforma de inversa de
la plaza si tienen dudas bueno aquí lo
vamos a hacer esperando que al resolver
este ejemplo se clarifique cualquier
duda o confusión
en alguno de los vídeos anteriores yo
les expliqué que la transformada de la
plaza de la segunda derivada de iu es
igual a s al cuadrado por la
transformada de la plaza de g
- s por ye evaluada en ser podemos
considerar esto como está realizando la
derivada recordamos que esta es una
integral que la transformada de la plaza
es una integral
esta 70 esta una derivada más lejos que
este término
- mi prima evaluada en 0 y podemos
reescribir esto en términos puramente
nacionales como en lugar de escribir la
transformada de la plaza de todo el
tiempo puedo escribir lo como s cuadrada
por ye mayúscula de s ya que la
transformada de la plaza está en función
de ese menos ese 90 menos ye prima de 0
estos van a ser números éstas no son
funciones son valores de la función
evaluar en cero y de la primera derivada
de la función evaluada en cero y ya
sabemos cuáles son estos valores los
tenemos aquí arriba este es 2
y prima de 0 es un 1 si calculamos la
transformada de la plaza de ambos lados
de esta ecuación primero queremos
encontrar la transformada de la plaza de
este término de aquí que es lo que
acabamos de hacer la transformada de la
plaza de la segunda derivada de ella que
es
s cuadrada por la transformada de la
plaza de la función que escribimos como
ye mayúscula de s
menos -2 s ya que nos dieron la
condición inicial de llevarlo a 0 que es
2 menos uno que es la primera derivada
de evaluar en cero y ahora queremos
encontrar la transformada de la plaza y
está ahí que es más ye mayúscula de s
transformada de la plaza de y aquí lo
escribimos ha transformado la plaza y es
igual a ye mayúscula de s
y esto va a ser igual a la transformada
en la plaza seno de 2 t
en un vídeo anterior ya les mostré cuál
es la transformada de la plaza de celo
de aporte pero la vamos a escribir aquí
para que la recordemos todos en color
rojo la transformada de laplace de seno
de a porte es igual a entre s cuadrada
más a cuadrada
/ s cuadrada masa cuadrada
por lo tanto la transformada de laplace
de seno de 2 t
sustituimos a por 2 y nos queda 2 entre
s al cuadrado más 2 al cuadrado que es 4
la transformada de la plaza de este otro
lado de la ecuación quedó como 2 / s
cuadrada más 4
y ahora lo que podemos hacer es separar
nuestros términos de s
factorizar este coeficiente aquí hay un
término y ese aquí hay otro y el lado
izquierdo de esta igualdad la escribimos
como s cuadrada que es este término
+ 1
ese cuadrado más 1 x
vamos a cambiar el color por estas de
ese porque de s
y ahora aquí ponemos los términos que no
tienen de s
- 2 s menos 1
que es igual a 2 / s cuadrada 4 podemos
sumar 2 s + 1 en ambos lados de esta
igualdad
y nos va a quedar ese cuadrado más uno
por jbs de bs
que es igual
a 2 / s cuadrada 4
+ 2 s más uno y ahora podemos dividir
ambos lados de la ecuación entre s
cuadrada más 1
quedándonos
la transformada de la plaza s que es
igual
a 2 vamos a cambiar color 2
/ s cuadrada más 4 multiplicando s
cuadrada más 1 qué es lo que está
dividiendo ambos lados de esta ecuación
s cuadrada más uno más dos es más uno
estos otros dos también os tengo que
dividir entre s cuadrada más uno
1 / s cuadrada más 1
y ahora para poder encontrar la
transformada inversa de todo esto
necesito dejarlas en una forma de
fracciones simples así como están están
un poco difíciles tendremos que hacer
una descomposición de fracciones para
encontrar fracciones más sencillas que
nos sean más fáciles de encontrar su
transformada inversa y en general esa es
la parte más difícil de este tipo de
problemas el álgebra necesaria para
poder descomponer esto en cosas más
sencillas y ahora cómo vamos a
descomponer esta parte voy a escribir
aquí abajo 2 / s cuadrada + 4 que
multiplica s cuadrada + 1
esto lo voy a descomponer en dos
fracciones esta es la descomposición de
fracciones parciales una fracción va a
tener el denominador es cuadrada más 4 y
la otra fracción tendrá el denominador
ese cuadrada más 1
ambos denominadores tienen un grado 2
por lo que los numeradores deberán tener
un grado 1 esto quiere decir que van a
tener un numerador del tipo a por s más
b y este otro tendrá un 1 de la forma se
puede ser más de esto es solamente
álgebra es descomposición de fracciones
parciales y ya hemos hecho algunos
vídeos explicando esto estoy asumiendo
que puedo expresar este término de acá
en dos fracciones y lo que necesito
hacer es encontrar los valores para a
para ver para se y para d
y para eso tengo que hacer la suma de
estas fracciones al hacer la suma voy a
tener que el denominador de todo esto va
a ser
s cuadrada más 4
por ese cuadrado más 1
y en el numerador voy a tener que
multiplicar a s
se ve por este denominador de acá ese
cuadrado más uno si nos quedamos así
pues estos dos términos se cancelarían y
tendríamos esta fracción original pero
tengo que agregar
ese es más de x este término de acá s
cuadrada 4
y vamos a ver si podemos simplificar los
términos de aquí tenemos que encontrar
los valores de a b c y d para que
coinciden con este 2 de acá
a ese más de por ese cuadrado más uno va
a quedar
a ese al cubo más a por s
+ b s cuadrada
y ahora multiplicamos esta otra parte de
acs de por s cuadrada más 4
nos queda por s al cubo más 4 c s
estos dos términos de acá nos queda
disculpen si se me escucha la voz un
poco rara es que estoy como agripada
pero todas maneras aquí estamos al pie
del cañón
bueno en que estaba yo así
más de por s al cuadrado
más de por 44 de eso es todo y no
escribí esta manera para poderme
asegurar de hacer bien las operaciones
de manera que los términos con los
mismos grados queden alineados y al
decir la suma me queda vamos a cambiar
de color
me queda a maze por s al cubo
más ponemos el término con es el
cuadrado después de más de x es el
cuadrado
más a 40 por s más ve más 4 d
y todo esto es solamente el numerador
y todo esto es lo que acabamos de
desarrollar acá
esto de aquí y yo creo que deberíamos
simplificar esto el denominador sigue
igual sigue estando ese cuadrada más 4
por s cuadrada más 1 aquí lo escribimos
s cuadrada más 4 por ese cuadrada más 1
este es el la fracción
y esto va a ser igual a esta otra cosa
de acá
2 / s cuadrada +4 por s cuadrada + 1
y la razón por la que he hecho todo este
desarrollo tan grande es porque
necesitamos encontrar los valores de abc
y de vemos que hace es el coeficiente
del término con una s al cubo y vemos
que de este otro lado no tenemos ese
tipo de coeficientes así que a más se
van a ser igual a 0 lo escribimos aquí a
más e es igual a 0
ya que aquí no hay ningún término que
tenga una vez el cubo vemos que es el
coeficiente bs al cuadrado pero de este
otro lado no tenemos nada en el
numerador con ese cuadrado por lo que ve
más de también va a ser igual a cero a
más 4 c es el coeficiente de ese y lo
mismo de este otro lado no tenemos nada
en términos de s
nuevamente lo escribimos a 4 c igual a
cero que bueno ya vimos que a maze era 0
por eso es una lógico que a más 4 c
también sea 0 y finalmente tenemos los
términos constantes y si tenemos un
término constante de este otro lado
tenemos al 2 por lo que ve más 4 d va a
ser igual a 2
4 de igual 2 y ahora nos toca encontrar
cuáles son los valores de b y d de
manera que toda esta expresión sea igual
a 2 y estas expresiones lineales no son
difíciles de resolver para eso vamos a
restar estas expresión de esta otra y
nos queda a menos a 0 c - 4 c igual a
menos 13 que todo esto es igual a cero
por lo tanto se va a ser igual a cero y
si vemos que se es igual a cero a más es
igual a cero por lo tanto a va a ser
igual a cero y vamos a hacer exactamente
lo mismo de este otro lado vamos a
restar esto de esto bmw es igual a cero
de menos cuatro de es igual a menos tres
de hicieron menos dos es igual a menos 2
nos queda que de va a ser igual a dos
tercios dividimos todo entre menos tres
menos dos entre menos tres queda dos
tercios
y encontramos tres valores de nuestras
cuatro variables y ahora necesitamos
encontrar cuál es el valor de b y aquí
una de las ecuaciones nos dice que ve
más d es igual a cero por lo que ve debe
ser igual que b pero con signo negativo
por lo que ve debe ser igual a menos dos
tercios para que a sumar menos dos
tercios más dos tercios sea igual a cero
y ahora si tenemos todos los valores que
necesitamos
2 / s cuadrada 4 por s cuadrada más 1 lo
podemos reescribir como si es 0 nos
queda aquí solamente b b es menos dos
tercios entre s cuadrada más 4 más la
otra fracción tenemos que ser es igual a
cero porque nos queda de ive es
dos tercios dos tercios / s cuadrada más
uno así que todo ese trabajo que
acabamos de hacer era simplemente para
descomponer esta pieza de acá solo para
descomponer esta pieza de acá en partes
más sencillas y ahora después de todo
este trabajo que es lo que nos queda
déjenme asegurarme de no equivocarme
aquí tenemos
la transformada de la plaza
s y como ven les dije el álgebra es la
parte más difícil de todo este problema
es igual a este primer término que ahora
tengo descompuesto en otras partes en
esto que acabamos de calcular vamos a
escribirlo de esta manera menos un
tercio
que multiplica a 2 / s cuadrada más 4
dos tercios que multiplican a 1 / s
cuadrada más 1
bueno le preguntarán por qué estás
escribiendo no de esta manera bueno
pueden ustedes darse cuenta de que esta
es la transformada de la plaza del seno
de 2t y esta es la transformada de la
plaza de 0 dt así que lo que quiero
escribir de esta manera para que me sea
más fácil encontrar la transformada
inversa y nos queda agregar
2 s / s cuadrada más 1
lo vamos a escribir en donde le
corresponde más
2 por s / s cuadrada más 1
más el último término 1 / s cuadrada más
uno
1 / s cuadrada más 1
y ahora sólo nos queda encontrar la
transformada inversa de la plaza cada
uno de estos términos y ya con eso
podemos encontrar cuál es el valor de g
vamos a recordar la transformada de la
plaza y bueno aquí estamos buscando la
transformada inversa lo voy a escribir
aquí para que quede claro y vean que no
me estoy sacando nada de la manga la
transformada de la plaza s lo de aporte
es igual a a / s cuadrada masa cuadrada
la transformada de la plaza del coseno
de porte es igual a s / s cuadrada masa
cuadrada
y esto es lo que vamos a usar para
encontrar la transformada inversa de la
plaza en ambos lados de esta ecuación la
transformada inversa de jbs va a ser
simplemente lleve t y esto va a ser
igual
esto es la transformada de la plaza seno
de 2 t nada más estamos encontrando los
patrones aquí si a es igual a 2 entonces
esta es la transformada de laplace de
seno de 2 t menos un tercio de seno de 2
t
más
dos tercios esta es la transformada de
la plaza del seno de t cuando a es igual
a 1 cuando a es igual a 1 la
transformada de la plaza el seno de t es
uno entre s cuadrada más son los más dos
tercios por el seno de t y vamos a hacer
el siguiente en azul para que quede más
claro más dos por esto es la
transformada de la plaza de coseno de t
si a es igual a 1 entonces esto es s / s
cuadrada más 1 la transformada de la
plaza del coseno de t y finalmente el
último término más vemos que es la
transformada de la plaza de seno dt
siendo igual a 1 y ya casi terminamos
aunque todavía tenemos que hacer algunas
simplificaciones tengo dos tercios del
seno de t aquí
y tengo seno de t acá así que dos
tercios más un entero cuánto es dos
tercios más un entero
reescribimos 7 es igual a menos un
tercio de seno de 2 t más
si agregan estos dos términos cinco
tercios
del seno de t
y nuestro último término más 2 coseno de
t vaya este problema fue bastante denso
y vimos que la parte más difícil fue
realizar toda la obra necesaria para
simplificar las fracciones la
descomposición de fracciones parciales
que hicimos con mucho cuidado aquí para
no cometer errores y al final obtuvimos
una respuesta bastante elegante y que
satisface nuestra incógnita inicial una
ecuación diferencial no homogénea espero
que hayan encontrado la resolución de su
problema bastante satisfactoria y nos
vemos en el siguiente vídeo